[Müzik]
Bu yüzden önce biraz dönüşüm üzerine
düşünelim
dönüşümü karşınıza alalım iyice bir
süzdüğümüz zaman anlarız ki dönüşümün
kendine kısıtlayan sınırları yoktur
tamaz Aslında bakarsanız kısıtlayamaz
Çünkü dönüşüm değişim demektir ve aynı
helaklitosunda söylediği gibi değişmeyen
tek şey değişimi kendisi
ancak
değişim ve dönüşüm çok ince ama net bir
çizgide birbirinden ayrılır
değişim elinizdekini aynı tutarak
elinizdekinin özünü aynı tutarak
gerçekleştir
di elinizdeki ne değiştir
irsiniz dönüşün bambaşka verir dönüşüm
kaostan Doğan mükemmelliktir Çünkü
dönüşüm radikaldir
dönüşüm eskisine dair her şeyi silerek
geliştir
günümüzde teknoloji sınırlarını dahi
kestiremeyeceğimiz bir çapta dönüş
eceğiz Bundan 20 yıl sonra günümüzde
günümüze dair bildiğimiz her şeyin
dönüşecek olması olası
ben de sizlere bu büyük dönüşümde çok
önemli bir yere sahip bir teknolojiden
bahsetmek istiyorum nesnelerin
interneti için meslek kavramı oldukça
geniş bir anlamına sahiptir Bu yüzden
önce akıllı sayıl
hangileri olduğunda bir göz at
alım bir cihazın akıllı sayılabilmesi ve
nesne olarak nit
elendiği 3 şartı karşıl
anması Bunlar akıllılığı sorgulanan
cihazın
özgün bir isme sahip olması günümüzde bu
çoğunlukla seri numaralı numaraları ile
ikinci olarak iletişim kurabilmesi ve
son olarak öğren
ebilmesi Böylece akıllılığı
her yerinden erişilebilir ve kontrol
edilebilir Hale
gelir nesnelerin interneti ise bu
kıllı cihazların
böyle anlatınca kafanızda Somut bir
nesnelerin interneti oluşmuyor
Tabi bu yüzden bir video izleyelim
nesnelerin
internete
size
nesnelerin internetinden çok
anlattığı anlatan
bu video aslında
tüm internetlerin
gelecek nesnelerin
insanından kaçamayız
Örneğin videoda gördüğünüz otomatik
perde saat saatin 7 olduğunu anladığında
bulunan Evde bulunan perdeye haber
veriyor ve her de kendiliğinden açılıyor
bakınız bu sürücünün kullandığı 3
otomatik olarak
ardından akıllı çöp Kut
usu geliyor bu daha ayrı bir cihaz Çünkü
dişlerimi fırçalayan küçük kardeşlerimiz
biten diş macunu çöpünü attıklarında çöp
bunu tarıyor ve
bunu fark ediyor evdeki Merkezi
sisteme alışveriş listesine ekliyorum
bitti almamız lazım diye
bilgilendiriyor
evde merkezi sistem olarak işleri gören
otomatik buzdolabı
akıllı demek daha doğrudur
size günün tarihini veya sizin daha
önceki tercihlerinize göre tarih
seçenekleri sunarak sizi
tavsiyelerde bulunuyor Ve siz bir tarih
seçtiğinizde
kendisinin içinde o gerekli malzemeleri
bulunur bulunmadığını kontrol ederek
alışveriş listesini güncelliyor
uzaktan evde yanımızda taşıdığımız
Evde bulunan tüm kil
saatimizden veya cep telefon
unuzdan ve basmıyorsunuz
saatinizden komut
veriyorsunuz ve kendinizi arıyor
Üstün tezgah olarak nitel
endirme sizin tarifin hangi aşamasında
olduğunuzu Neyi kaç gram ölçtüğünüzden
yola çıkarak anlıyor videoda onu ölçtüğü
sütünün sıcaklığına baktığı ve
farketti ki Bir sonraki aşamada fırına
ihtiyaç olacak fırını ön hazırlık için
bakın
anlayış bir zaman gidip soralım
düğmesine basmadım
bu öğrenebilen nesnelerin
biriyle
iletişim video bize geleceğin evleri
hakkında da bilgi verdi nesnelerin
interneti
videoda izlediğimiz tüm Bu cihazlar
ve yoğun bir iletişim halinde
buzdolabı olarak
işletilen Evin her yerinden Eriş
ilebilir Aslında bu
erişmeleri tam olarak da nesn
elerin fotoğrafta gördüğünüz çizgiler
nesnelerin internetini temsil ediyor
buzdolabı telefona haber veriyor klima
telefona buzdolabı
telefonu ama nesnelerin
elerin en az
bu olan bir işlevi daha var
nesnelerin interneti sadece akıllı
olarak nitel
nesnelerin interneti büyük cihazlar
arasında
değil Ve bu
titanlar arasındaki iletişim hatlarından
veri ve bu taşıdığı verileri yapay
zekanın
diye düzenler
düzenlerle bilgiye çevirir
bol veri ürünleri bizim için bir anlamı
ifade etmez ama Bilgi önemlidir
bu bilgi toplama işleminin cid
ve dinleniyoruz
internetteki yaptıklarımız inceleniyor
ve bizim aklımızda bir dosya olur bizim
hakkımızda kavramlar bulunan dosyalar
oluştur
uluyor o zaman
bizden en yakından tanıdığınız
iye güzel en derin
sırları onları kaç kelime veya kavramla
anlat
abilirsin ben de
kendisini en yakından tanıdığını
tanıdığını düşündüğüm insanı düşündüm
ve onu kavramlara indir
Edim bunun üzerine düşündükten sonra
bunu ver 15 kavramda yapabildim
15k
baktığınız zaman 16 yaşında olarak
ve kendisini çok uzun zamandır tanıyorum
ama ben Yaşım kadar her seneyi bir
kavram ayırsan bile kendisini yeterince
iyi tanımıyorum
işte nesnelerin interneti ile yapay zeka
bizim internetteki ayak izimizi aynı bir
dedektif gibi inceler
hangi uygulamaları kullanıyoruz hangi
uygulamayı ne kadar kullanıyoruz neyin
fotoğrafını çekiyoruz hangi üründe ne
kadar süre
bakıyor bize daha Hayır internetteki
ayeti temsil eden her şeyi en derin
noktasına kadar inceliyor ve bizi
kavramlara indiriyor
bizim 15 kavramda yaptığımız analizi
nesnelerin interneti onbinler
ve bu anlayacağınız nesnelerin interneti
kavram veri transferi ile bilgi
oluşturur ve bilgi de değerlidir
bilgi kullanmasını bilen için değerlidir
Bilgin kullanmasını bilen için güçtür
yani
bilginin kendisi
güçlü ülkelerin savunma sanayiinde artık
asker sayısı önemini yitirdi
teknoloji yerine aldı
bilgiye sahip olan
güçlüdür kazanmanın bilgisine sahip olan
zaferi yarısını kazanmış demektir
ve bu yüzden gelecekte bilginin Efendisi
olan güçlü
olacak ve bilginin Efendisi
olmak için bilginin Efendisi olabilmek
için çalışmanın
uşağı olmaması
gerektiğini ancak gelecek bize
gösteriyor ki gelecekte bilgilerin
Efendisi olmak için çalışmanın değil
teknolojinin
uşağı olmamız gerekecek teşekkürler
[Alkış]